Superman who? Dwayne Johnson seems poised
to turn the DC Universe upside-down with
the release of "Black Adam" next week, at least
according to those who've already seen the movie.
Early reviews for the Warner Bros. flick have
it pegged as an overwhelmingly brutal and
honest take on the Black Adam character,
who "literally kills anyone and everyone
in his way," per Collider's Steven
Weintraub. He wrote in his review:
"[Johnson]'s fantastic as Black Adam ... and
I loved that he didn't pull
back on who Black Adam is."
For those who might not know, DC's "Black Adam"
seemed destined to fail in many people's eyes
with all the woes that Warner Bros. has
experienced as of late. Back in March,
the film was reportedly pushed back
from a summer release to October 21,
2022, due to COVID-related production
delays involving its visual effects.
Producer Hiram Garcia explained
the situation to The Wrap, saying:
"I think we're just in a world right now where
there was a huge and understandable freeze-up
when the pandemic hit and a lot of productions
were put on hold. Now that the industry has
really roared back, the pipeline for VFX is
so jammed ... and we're just in a situation
where the majority of the VFX houses
are just completely swamped with work."
With this in mind, many people feared that "Black
Adam" was doomed to fail in the
eyes of critics and audiences.
But according to people who got early screenings
of "Black Adam," the DC film is unlike
any comic book movie that's come before
it — with one critic even describing
it as a "300-style action spectacle."
Critic Paul McGuire Grimes tweeted that it was,
quote, "Epic on Every Level." Similarly,
Screen Rant's Joe Deckelmeier tweeted:
"#BlackAdam is a game-changer! [Dwayne
Johnson] is electrifyingly brutal as
Black Adam! ... The action in
the film is non-stop & seeing
the [Justice Society of America]
on the big screen was a thrill!"
While it definitely looks like there are a
few things in the movie worth griping about,
the overall consensus for "Black Adam" seems to
be that it's a possible scale-tipper for DC's
Extended Universe following Marvel's recent
missteps with critically-lukewarm films like
"Black Widow," "Eternals," "Doctor Strange
in the Multiverse of Madness," and "Thor:
Love and Thunder." Some people have even wondered
if fans are getting tired of Marvel movies now in
the wake of the conclusion to the decade-long
Infinity Saga. If the early reviews of "Black
Adam" are true, then Johnson may not have been
ambitious enough when he said this sentiment.
"The hierarchy of power in the
DC universe is about to change."
For many reviewers, DC's "Black Adam" isn't
just a breath of fresh air for the Hollywood
superhero genre, but all of the DCEU as a
whole. Ben Rolph of DiscussingFilm tweeted:
"#BlackAdam is DC's most action-packed film
to date. It's a non-stop thrill ride that
is all about spectacle, and it knows it."
He also added,
"[Dwayne Johnson] is a perfect Black
Adam, plus Pierce Brosnan is a standout."
Content creator and entertainment journalist Matt
Ramos hasn't seen "Black Adam" yet, but he fully
expects the film to help shift the tide for Warner
Bros. and DC Films. On October 12, Ramos tweeted:
"If #BlackAdam is as GREAT as the reviews
say, DC might've slammed Marvel this year."
In a separate tweet, which came later
in the night as more and more reviews
for "Black Adam" rolled in, Ramos
declared, quote, "DC is back."
While the Marvel vs. DC rivalry may be fun for
fans and critics, it's something that the movie
stars themselves apparently don't pay much mind to
— or at least that's how Dwayne Johnson sees it.
"I kneel before no one."
In an October 12 interview at
the New York City premiere of
"Black Adam," he told the Associated Press:
"Do I think we are going to take any kind of bite
out of Marvel? That answer is unequivocally no."
Johnson added,
"We don't want to be Marvel. We want to be DC. And
how we do things. So that's what I want. I don't
want to take a bite of that apple. I want to grab
a new apple. And I want to create from there."